nämlich um gras hin kommt wissen wir
jetzt eine holz geheizt mit holz im eine
holztreppe von unten nach oben führen
damit das gras überwuchert wechselt
einfach online herr oder wir nehmen uns
ganz kurzen grasbrook unter fisch meist
mit einem block weg nein das machen wir
ja aber das dauert wirklich jahre
nein dann machen wir es so dass wir da
dass wir damit kochen werden vielleicht
geht es auch so nein das geht nicht du
musst das echt so wachsen lassen es dort
wirklich jahre alt jahre
die müssen sich das dach jetzt gleich
benutzen dann warten wir ab bis das dach
gewachsen ist einfach andere sachen
machen felix hier wird wenn man ein buch
in crafting table reinlegt kommt man ihn
wie ein anderes buch raus da kriegt man
einen link in buch making a ja davon
habe ich in dem video gesehen und zwar
kann man das aus bonn setzen und so was
alles watte linking book rechtsklick auf
world ja da kann man auf jeden fall so
sachen eingeben
ok jetzt haben auf jeden fall ein link
in burg was genau zu bringen wird könne
auch die kommentarschreiber tisch
zaubert tisch brauchen wir aber
definitiv bücherregale okay warum uns
einen extra raum dafür machen ich leider
für machen uns ein kleinen tempel für
diesen tisch nach oben dann später mal
gucken
ich setze erstmal hier direktionen bitte
so
ich kann mich zu 100 anfangen mit dem
wasser der lava ist es sie zu extrem
ausfindig
was das passt findest du es passt okay
kommt open erhält sofort jetzt auch
übrigens 20 und 22 jahre eine folge auf
also noch acht minuten dann muss ich
denke bei dem spiel spaß und ich muss am
abend essen und wenn wasserspiel das
muss natürlich live verfolgen männer
wette ich hab dir doch er hingeschmissen
zwei echte noch welche geben
wir haben ja gibt noch leisten denn
bevor da ist schlafen erst mal
trainieren
also scheint den roman fertig gute nacht
zu schlafen
also warte hier ist das 164
ok ich schon sagen weiter hier soll was
drin hier soll 64
na ja es reicht mit auch nicht haben
jetzt schon um habe ich schon ein
erdacht
du nimmst die 64er doktor willst oder
nicht und macht eine falltür schnell wir
noch eine falsche weil ich mache schon
jetzt hier oben noch einhändig hin weil
wir noch zwölf kisten übrig
obwohl das machen was ich können
passagiere die macht man so ne ich komme
wieder da hinten drauf und die ganzen
anderen räume sind und da uns vielleicht
ein bisschen dings holen hat sich jetzt
erst mit wasser
märz auf die spitze
die andere
so ich jetzt den anderen roboter bäumen
was ist gut er unser falsch ist gut wenn
man wenn man label ok ich weiß hier der
treppe hoch es wird jetzt erstmal der
ersten zeitlich schön aussehen aber es
muss sein
doch ganz ganz viele treppen hoch ich
wäre dafür dass wir irgendwann das ist
so ein bisschen mit so bahnen vernetzen
und so bin ich auch dafür
stehe ich voll drauf ja ich weiß ernst
ich finde es aber wirklich irgendwie
folgen zu denken ist jetzt auch ganz
viel kerosin sehe ich hier in dem hier
ist alles voll mit diesen ganzen bäume
diesen rabatt ries ist ein rabatt region
oder so hinderlich für dich paar
setzlinge mit abklatschen
das schön dass ich mal was machst du
eigentlich gerade sie die erde die das
gras hof unter dach ja das sind übrigens
ein paar sätze die monarchisten ja wenn
sie ist immer da steht auf die bauern
sitzen das nämlich nicht alle bäume
ich habe keine zäune die erste typ alle
gucken muss sich um den baum fahren wir
schon voll eingebracht haben abgemacht
das haben wir so abgemacht sieht zwar
schön aus mit dem setzen wenn man
dienstes wird reingehen muss nach vorne
bleibt aber das viel besser da ist viel
besser
das wird gehört man kriegt wieso ich hab
so was geht vielleicht etwas essen das
hier wird ein riesiger erdwall so viel
rabatt so scheiße aus ich brauche ich
fälle dass nur ob damit er die setzlinge
runterfallen haben wir also deine
hintergrund meine wahre taktikerin war
es meine wahren ziele aber vielleicht
auch schon 22 gisin ist gut ich freue
mich schon auf morgen einfach den
kompletten tag hochland für die nächste
woche
weil dann fängt beim media klausurphase
animusx l
das ist mittlerweile so alle möglichen
mord videos aufnehmen kann
wahrscheinlich nicht dieses video seht
ist bei mir sogar rat wieder tritt fasse
ich bin froh dass ich die ganzen sachen
jetzt aufnehmen kann weil dann kann ich
die nachher so verteilt hochladen und
übrigens sieht reviews also für die idee
gerade bei mir zu schauen die werden
auch bald wiederkommen da braucht jetzt
nicht wieder fragen das ist noch so ich
habe auch material also ich bin da
wirklich reichlich zu nur fehlt mir im
moment einfach die geduld mit einem welt
rein zu setzen und keine ahnung ich hab
ich nicht ein warum ich diese zeit nicht
aufnehmen na ja erst mein wissen
weitergeben
ich habe übrigens sieben setzlinge für
dich das ist gut
danke ich weiß nicht ob ich mal paar
pilze mitnehmen du stehst voll drauf ich
würde vor dass er richtig geil wenn wir
so ein maximum findet hätte mir nie
wieder probleme mit irgendwelchen essen
wenn man einfach diese dings hätten
immer schon früher wo wir dann etwa mit
einer schale hingehen können
rechts klicken dann haben wir die suppe
echte gipfel ja dass das geil an denen
wusste ich noch gar nicht geil es habe
ich als erste frau wird auf jeden fall
so eine kuh holen
ich werde doch ersten und zwei und man
ihn überhaupt 6 ich möchte unbedingt die
stäbe geil ist damit wächst das neue
cool dann hast du ausgesagt
ich weiß noch unser erdwall hier dann
mit places liste aufnehmen ist schon
gewachsen müsst ihr dann standen fragen
ich komme jetzt erstmal wieder zurück
ich freue mich zu ende
an den rücken jetzt hier zwar gerade
ihre ganzen setzlingen rund habe ich hab
schon zwölf und ich will sagen das
reicht erst mal wenn wir diese baum
fahrfertig haben dann haben wir haben da
ja schon neuen bäume +12 0 21 9 21 von
diesen komischen bäumen und das wird
schon immens groß und die werfen dann
wiederum versetzt linke ab und das
ergänzt sich alles richtig doch viel
lieber jetzt die krisen habe ich 25
das gut und wer mir zu hause auch die
ganzen bäume können doch was runter soll
ich jetzt noch einmal die langsam komme
ich zurück mit stopp und dann heißt es
für euch wieder kommentare schreiben
einerseits was heißt dieser blog da vor
5 6 folgen oder so den ich euch da
gezeigt habt ihr da im wald stand
einfach so kann ich nur ganz kurz hängen
ich habe 40 sekunden vorbei was heißt
dieser blog
wie major general electric arc furnace
seine e-mails rage generator und elektro
fans aneinander anordnen oder die so war
das ja und auch noch was wir mit den
drohnen machen müssen weil das hatte ich
schon mal gefragt und da habe ich keine
antwort darauf bekommen weil das keine
so richtig wusste mit den drohnen
was sollen wir mit denen machen es
meinten ja einige leute dass ich die
drohne einfach mit rechtsklick irgendwo
hinsetzen kann und dass die dann einfach
immer mit mir rum fliegt und alles tötet
was einfach so im umkreis ist obwohl das
wollte ich noch ausprobieren ausprobiert
ich bin auf dem weg zurück lässt sich
das neue text werde dich vermissen
oder ich hätte noch zehn minuten auf den
folgenden link ist ja so ein hunger er
kommt nur eine folge
man legt er noch einmal einfach käfig
ist zwar kein großer unterschied aber